السودانيون من ولايه غرب دارفور مستمرون
في مغادره منازلهم والوصول الى تشاد هنا
في هذا الموقع سجلت المفوضيه العليا
للاجئين نحو 4000 لاجئ سوداني وصلوا حديثا
الى جاد بعد اندلاع الحرب في السودان
سليمان ابراهيم وصل الى هذه المنطقه قادما
من بلده مستريحه بولايه غرب دارفور
[موسيقى]
محل المنظمات عشان يكفينا عشان كده
من اي منطقه
لحظات وترفيه لاطفال هذه الاسره التي وصلت
الى هذا الموقع قبل يومين
ومعظم اللاجئين في هذا الموقع هم من
النساء والاطفال
من هنا يحصل اللاجئون على الماء
كميات قليله لا تكفي لسد احتياج اللاجئين
يحصل السكان المحليون ايضا على المياه من
هذه الابار
اسباب اللجوء الى هنا متعدده
ومعظم القادمين الى تشاد من السودان
يتحدثون عن الاشتباكات العرقيه ومسلحي
القبائل باعتبارهم السبب الاول لتشريد
السودانيين من دارفور الى تشاد
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
كونغر منطقه قادريه على الحدود الشاديه
السودانيه